live from the Jon Lovitz comedy club
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] on I'm the fat one
and I'm the not quite as fat one I like
to think of you as the handsome one oh
good thing we're in a podcast and not
television sir thank you so much for
coming out to the Lovitz here for
Hollywood babble-on he's Kevin Smith I'm
Ralph Garman big night for us tonight
we're very excited
huge night we grow up tonight folks
Babylon enters the major leagues finally
finally somebody thinks we're sponsor
worthy yes well we got a sponsor tonight
and rather than just go recording that
we're gonna do it live with you guys
right here in the room the sponsor is
man great yeah
[Music]
man great seems like a joke isn't it
man great is a grill enhancement system
remain great we'll make you take your
meat your chicken your fish grill with
the [ __ ] to hell man like do it right
and [ __ ] but I don't know jack [ __ ]
about grilling I'll be honest with you
so what I did was bring in a
professional to tell us about the
grilling system the man great grilling
system how effective it is ladies and
gentlemen professor Thaddeus T marinade
oh my goodness how are you everyone such
a pleasure to be here on your show Kevin
and Ralph oh he's right you're very
handsome Ralph we're lucky to have you
here tonight professor you are yes we
know how busy your schedule cannot you
know I'm just busy grilling all the time
I'm a grilling fool that's what I do 24
hours a day a mindless leap just
grilling a man who grills
I'm a griller of man who grills I'm a
man a man who grill so you need man
grace I know the man great intimately
you couldn't have a better sponsor this
thing its first of all it's made in
America number one which is great
because you know foreigners are bad we
all know that and you put it right on
your grill and it makes it like a
steakhouse grill you know yes total man
grates are 100% made in America the
heavy-duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to start grilling
like a pro today it makes it like a
steakhouse grill on top of your own
grill so the flames don't get through
and dry out to me nothing's worse than
dry me just ask her she knows
nothing worse than tough dry meat how do
you like to meet moist how do you keep
your meat
lubricated well I'm a marinade ER my
family invented the marinade right but
using the using the man grade it keeps
your meat moist and succulent I'm sorry
the teeth are loose succulent it
couldn't be a better gift for Father's
Day you know Father's Day coming up you
know it is actually she looks like me
let's leave it at that
well it's a great gift for Dad because
usually you get him something that sucks
like smelly cologne or a tie or a lava
lamp or something right but this will
actually enjoy and they'll drill you up
some meaning it'll be good he could put
this on the grill slap his feet on it
yet chicken or beef or fish but not fish
from Tokyo cuz it glows in the dark now
why radiation don't you know don't you
know how much is this Master grilling
system the man grave definitely 1995 No
1999 it just went up the price is rising
all the time apparently how do they get
to it they get to it by clicking on the
man great banner yet at SModcast calm
slash Babylon on the Babylon page
they'll see an ad for man great there
click on that get the man great but $20
dude that'll be so happy it'll be like
you left the house all over again
remember le happy was when you left the
house why why was he happy they didn't
like you Catherine I thought it's just
cuz he wanted to [ __ ] mom
your mama my mom a lesson if you order
now you get a free heavy-duty man great
grilling brush thrown in as an extra
from me personally I'm going to brush in
the box
professor marinade is gonna throw in a
brush I'll put a grilling brush in why
because that's the kind of person I am
that's how I roll don't you know if this
brush you haven't used it or anything
have you no it's brand-new sanitized for
your protection how do they get to the
man great people again they get to man
great by going to SModcast comm slash
Babylon the Babylon page click on the
man grave banner or you could just
Google man grit as well
every order comes a man great grilling
brush these guys the only people in the
world who thought that we were worth
sponsoring they're kind of like that
they may have been wrong yes they're
kind of like Chico's Bail Bonds in the
bad news bears you know everyone else
has Pizza Hut [ __ ] like that we got man
grace shown that you love Babylon show
them that you love them for supporting
us go get yourself a twenty dollar
[ __ ] man great kit right now what are
you waiting for our thanks and let's
give it up for man great no I have some
meat on the grill professor thank you
for stopping by
anytime we might fall on your surfaces
again in the future if we're lucky if
you're lucky you can't afford me anymore
alright now transform back into ralph
like this professor walked oh no once
you shake it off like you just like
you're [ __ ] jacqueline i like what
happened of it well wasn't it what time
is it
blacked out there for a minute and be
awesome if you blacked out became
professor Thaddeus marinade you came to
and everyone had their dicks in your
face and we were all taking pictures of
[ __ ] I wouldn't be on it was on the man
great website I was thinking I wake up
hungry for steak or something I didn't
please be waking up with a lot of meat
in your face man great go try it out
welcome to Hollywood babble-on man we're
ready to get the show going alright
as always we start up with some shout
out to people who came particularly long
distances or we're celebrating special
occasions our Andrew and Mike here and
Drew and Mike you guys here right there
hey guys hey guys what's with the long
delay yeah he's like anybody a manager
Mike here quiet and then [ __ ] I'm Andrew
oh it's the I'm not gay hesitation I say
we don't have that here in Hollywood
yeah
we'll think about it later so manly
space yeah my buddy Mike is his birthday
today andrew says his wife had to work
so I decided to the right thing not let
him stay home tonight and celebrate
alone but buy him a ticket to the best
show in town
unfortunately Mamma Mia doesn't come
back to LA until June so I brought him
here instead so far the [ __ ] audience
is funnier than the tablet yeah
tonight
yeah the Mamamia reference gave it away
there Andrew I don't care how long you
waited to say your name tonight's my
first time to the Lovitz says Ulysses
Ulysses here tonight it was just there
he is right there is your name really
Ulysses you're like a superhero dude you
can't what do you do right now in life
retweet I'm not good enough not with a
name like Ulysses cure cancer AIDS find
a Martian open a wormhole in space that
name is a responsibility so live up to
it retail it wasn't the answer you know
I wanna be like what do I do for a
living I'm a god amongst human beings
like I thought so welcome God Ulysses
hell of a name I'm Ulysses I'm Ulysses
would you like to see those in a size 8
okay super to you is this and I can't
see Ulysses tonight.you Ulysses Ulysses
that's right that you let Caesar Ulysses
Ulysses seize the Seas and Missy are
here tonight my girlfriend hates the
fact that I spent so much time listening
to podcast yours included so I decided
to bring her
[Music]
now she hates it even more Ravi did was
make fun of EULA Ulysses he couldn't
even say her name I'm the fat one and
tomatoes that you're a loser why would
you bring her the rub her face in it
he's like I thought this plan through I
was awesome though there his name's
Ulysses her name is Missy Missy
Missy's Ulysses that's cute man are you
guys just dating yeah how long you been
doing [ __ ] years
[ __ ] Ulysses pull the trigger yes the
name of a god you date like a [ __ ] 30
year old man five years you got to seal
the deal Missy come on man what is it
we're young how old are you oh honey 23
oh don't get married
wait wha Ulysse SATs using a 1920s
gangster voice can you welcome her and
threatened her into listening to more
podcasts just did oh I'm angry 2011
voice actually 1920s gangster voice okay
listen here you dizzy named those things
on the side of your head aren't just
fellatio handles their ears you hear
hear
now put in the yoga listen to some
podcasts or else you'll get a big slice
of five-knuckle pie you understand what
I'm saying the business end of a fist a
fist I say from that golden American age
when you couldn't threaten a woman
apparently twenties Chelsea and Kyle
Chelsea and Kyle here know right next to
Ulysses and Missy oh my god you guys
come together just meeting right now
right
my name is Chelsea I brought my
boyfriend Kyle to this show Saturday
night to celebrate his birthday
we're both Babylon virgins so you've
popped our Babylon cherries together
well thank you very much mmm but
listening the podcast since day one it
would mean so much to both of us have
Ralph wished Kyle a happy birthday and
it's Arnold Schwarzenegger voice who
knows if we leave satisfied I mean might
even let him out anal sex tonight a lot
of pressure on us I couldn't see her
because she was all hairy she put her
head right down but now that I see her
well done let me tell you something
first of all you should marry her and
then like 25 years later get a divorce
that's what I recommend but make sure
you you know you know it punctured a
balloon at first you know make it count
tonight and then you know you'll be back
and wear a condom
wanted to grow on my husband and I are
going to the show is part of our four
year anniversary celebration this is
from Debbie and Derrick or Debbie and
Derrick here there you guys are have
ballons welcome to the bellmen happy
four year anniversary since i love him
and he loves you both watching you live
is a way to show him my love gay I know
she writes yeah don't use us as the glue
in your [ __ ] married yeah that's bad
if you're relying on us your Fox start
talking to one another Lord Lord you
love them find a guy who's into women
that's another can you wish Derek Bauman
a happy anniversary from Debbie no sorry
Debbie we don't do that sort of thing
now I kept the university gave here
Gabriel Martinez and his wife and his
brother yeah where are you guys there
you are right back there Gator
celebrating his 37th birthday
he says 37 being a rather apropos for a
Kevin Smith related function 37 yeah
he says keeping with the show's motto
all anal all the time I didn't know that
was our motto by the way
I hadn't told you it but it seems you're
working the clubs Phil you know the man
great folks know about that that's why
they're here man great book some
commercial time on that Anil program
I've heard so much about when he wants
the main Old Market in a man great
Gabriel says in keeping with the all
Anil all the time motto thought it might
have been written on the box I was
hoping to hear a little conversation
between Peter Lorre and Charlton Heston
imagine it's 1960 he said he's give me
characters a time a place he's give any
more to work with than I have ever done
well done
alright convincing my wife to give up
the o-ring so Peter Lorre and Charlton
Heston in 1960 are having a conversation
about her [ __ ] all right all right
here we go Charlton counting are you
going to vote for Kennedy or for Nixon
is there I haven't decided yet Peter
I get the sense that Kennedy may be a
gun control nut he certainly will be in
a few years but how would I know that
because it's only night you 60 more
important ransom you arrested mr. Heston
more importantly we have to tell
Gabriel's wife to give up the [ __ ]
goddamn paws off her sphincter you dirty
ape and see there are a lot of [ __ ]
anal virgins in the room every week
everyone's always like if they come here
like it's the wailing wall or something
an important place if you want to get
some anal like this is where you're
gonna go I don't know how these dudes
can make it happen
Amelia and Nick are you guys here where
are you where are you guys oh there you
are there's an accent that boys yeah the
reason I want to say hi to them they
just got here this morning from Sydney
Australia 7,500 miles they can
as we say boy we don't say that an
either today anymore no no this is their
honeymoon trip to the US for the
honeymoon decided to come see his first
thing off so he also says it would be
truly special with Al Pacino could
provide some advice on how I could treat
my new wife in the bedroom to ensure we
can sustain the passion for the rest of
our lives and maybe get to experience
Kevin's favorite method of doing the do
which of course I would like I would
like to crack that's not true I'm not a
big you know I'm an ass eater myself oh
here he comes
she's a nasty eater so when I say ain't
no I don't mean just the act of n I'm
more talking about my whole life without
ever seeing that you just never once be
in the same room and see it coming at
you know you'd respect me a lot more
I'll tell you that I'm looking at you
quite right
Nick Nick also as he's aware of the
performing monkey aspect of this request
so he wants to donate $200 to my
favorite charity in exchange for the
entertainment we've given him over the
past thirty two or so podcast thank you
so much yeah well done
oh so so now I got to do it
I got a do Al Pacino
oh come on now with the new wife from
Down Under
Oh Down Under is a good place to start
Nick I would eat a [ __ ] then have you
know have Kevin eat ur ass warm her up
come on now she'll be begging for it beg
for it
Thank You Nick welcome can I can I ever
quick request a quick battle off
impression off you against yourself one
syllable impression you against yourself
Al Pacino Charlton Heston it's a battle
of the oh and here we go on the count of
three one two now come I already did all
right last I shot it real quick coming
with a few friends tonight totally
nervous one of my friends is totally
nervous because she is in love love love
love with Kevin shocking I know would
Kevin mind calling her out to make her
even more uncomfortable her name is
whimsy Wednesday where are you where's
wins D how do you pronounce your name
we're third level oh we're up top all
the way up top three how do you
pronounce your name when way but it's
spelled Wyn SD ey who named you Mariah
Carey
Wednesday that's not Wednesday it's
Wednesday it's Wednesday Wednesday
anyway she's she's in love love love
with you
oh I'll change that by the end of the
night yeah welcome Wednesday do you
really love love love him really why
because it's an ass freak okay emails so
it's time for the email bag song please
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions yes this is
from Gabe just wanted to know what kind
of movie you guys would like to make
with Liam Neeson but instead of waiting
for an answer I made this movie poster
instead hope you like it
babble the [ __ ] on gay put us in the 18
I'm I'm the Bradley Cooper role there I
have my head on his body you're a Mad
Dog
totally yeah and then the the tagline of
the poster is huge explosions huge [ __ ]
credits right there thank you Gabe I
appreciate that
dear Ralph would you please do a spoken
word version of Rebecca Black's Friday
as William Shatner the real William
Shatner has ignored my request for him
to do it so I hope your cheap knockoff
will last us until he far as falling up
out of the public eye and does it
himself well how could I resist with
it's such a lovely invitation 7 a.m.
gotta wake up in the morning gotta be
fresh gotta go downstairs
I gotta have my bowl gotta have cereal
seeing everything time is goin tickin on
and on everybody's rushin gotta get down
to the bus stop gotta catch my bus see
my friends kickin in the front seat
sittin in the backseat gotta make up my
mind which seat can I take
it's Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday Ralph and cab my wife listen to
you guys on a regular basis we're
planning to come and see you live soon
when we do we will bring you one of our
special HBO sandwiches picture attached
apparently this is a sandwich that they
make at home literally give that penis a
sandwich
it is a penis sandwich it looks like
pretzel bread so it's extra delicious
you know I would so eat that many time
I've had a dick in my mouth said I wish
this was a pretzel instead this combines
two great times I've had a pretzel
around I said I wish this was a dick
instead we're such a great team Ralph
and Kevin my name is Luigi from
Harrisburg Pennsylvania
I love the podcast listen to it all the
other live all the time
the other day I brought my mom to her
doctor's appointment and on the way I
had Babylon playing in the car she asked
me what the hell I was listening to then
I spent the car ride explaining the
origins of things like give that penis a
sandwich and let's all go inside after I
was done speaking she replied by saying
I'm glad I'll be dead soon
thank you for making my mom look forward
to the grave Louise glad to know we're
serving a purpose do you think that name
became more popular after like a
generation like after the videogame
Luigi yeah wasn't the Mario Brothers I'm
imagining right cuz the [ __ ] names their
kid Luigi anymore
somebody who really likes that you're
there from it's an Italian family where
Luigi probably no I'm sure they're from
a family had two boys and they're like
Oh Mario Luigi I guess Geoff caps on put
him in overalls and big overstuffed
gloves I'm gonna pipes are clogged they
sewn down to the sewers his last emails
from Dustin he says I've been a big
friend of Kevin Smith for years and I've
heard him reference hitting people with
chairs several times what the [ __ ] is
that all about I told ya I don't like
people change no but I wanted to once
I'm one occasion Timothy Olyphant the
actor Timothy only Ola fantastic yeah
you wanted to hit him with a chair we
were on catch and release and he said
some kind of snide to me and I was like
I want to [ __ ] pick up a chair and go
prison on him I figured that'd be the
only way to get respect on the set did
you know bored one night I created Kevin
Smith in a wrestling video game and
created a quick clip of him kicking
spider-man's ass with a chair here's the
link on YouTube from Dustin ie it was I
pulled it up on YouTube this is you
kicking spider-man in a wrestling ring
it's it there you are you're flipping
them over and out of nowhere there's a
chair in your chair I thought that might
be cathartic for you yeah Tim Olaf on
under that mask I hate it's time as we
do every week do you have to say goodbye
to someone in show business with our
Tinseltown steps and now
[Music]
they will be missed pretty good week
this week not too many people dying the
only one I caught was a legendary
character actress by the name of Dana
Wynter she was one of the good ones a
British actress who worked forever
really from the 50s all the way up to
the 90s did a whole bunch of television
a whole bunch of movies but primarily
she was known as the co-star in invasion
of the body snatchers the original 1950s
invasion of the body snatchers with
Kevin McCarthy about the pod people who
come down and take over while you're
sleeping and make you into an alien it
was sort of a thinly veiled commentary
on the McCarthy McCarthy era politic Red
Scare right she passed away this week at
the age of 79 so I thought as a tribute
to her we'd play a little clip of
invasion of the body snatchers this is
her Kevin McCarthy he's with her she's
already turned into a pod person she
doesn't know he doesn't know that yet
until he kisses her and that's when he
realizes that she's cold to the touch
[Music]
should never affect you stop acting like
a fool my acceptance never [ __ ]
[ __ ] every time they will just [ __ ]
up your life no down here is janam
they're breaking up with you or they're
turning into [ __ ] pod people aliens
and then you know like turning you it
turn you into the other aliens he passed
away at 17 he will be messing about
gonna win that counted young lady say
look at the new releases coming out this
weekend everything must go and limited
release the new Will Ferrell comedy with
our buddy Stephen Drew all right he's in
red state yes he is
priest opens this weekend as well Paul
Bettany stars as a priest who has to
take on vampires priest is in 3d so if
you if you bring kids in the theater be
careful because the priest is in 3d and
it will be so touchy
and right what's it's a superhero movie
no fries yeah it's kind of it's based on
a Japanese comic book he's kind of like
a superhero type figure like a Batman
kind of well it's more like zip no but I
who's laughing
I can still know [ __ ] even though I
didn't see it actually I did the panel
for this at comic-con right yeah yeah
and it sort of is what's the it's like a
fantasy thriller thing more than it is a
superhero thing it's like another world
kind of thing where the the vampires and
the regular people have learned sort of
the co-exist and the truce is broken
when his niece is kidnapped and he has
to go all all ballistic on the on the
vampire the priests nice
the priests yeah that originally was
priests nice and they changed them so
let's just call priests and bridesmaids
opens this weekend as well to Kristen
Wiig Maya Rudolph Rose bursts and works
so [ __ ] funny my Rudolph's really
funny too I saw this weekend you'll see
this weekend it's very funny I really
enjoyed it Kristen Wiig is a friend of
mine we did a show together a couple
years ago called the Joe Schmo show yeah
which was a spoof of reality television
and it was her first sort of big break
and television certainly was mine and
she was a so amazing even in that we all
kind of looked each other said she's
gonna be a big star someday and now
she's on Sara alive and making movies
and won't answer my phone calls all
right let's take a look at some of the
headlines this week to a half man was in
the news big time first they told us
Hugh Grant was in the running to take
over for Charlie Sheen is not an
emotional journey they said it for those
of us so invested on who in who's gonna
replace Charlie Sheen man there were
highs there were lows and then
everything kind of worked out the way
well it should I guess you grant
originally was said to be in the running
for $1,000,000 per episode and then
reportedly negotiations broke down
mm-hmm and they went to their second
choice who was Ashton Kutcher do you
think who the things with Hugh Grant
broke down cuz he was just like yeah
I'll do it then it was like wait what is
it now
don't f what yeah totem in episode yeah
really
that's [ __ ] shite am I going to have
to wear those bad bowling shirts Ashton
Kutcher's have returned into the
television of course he got his big
break on that 70 show now he's going to
replace Charlie Sheen on Two and a Half
Men for what they're saying is about a
million dollars per episode really see
this is it feel if honestly when they
announced it it felt like they looked at
Charlie Sheen they were like okay he's
got like 3.8 million followers on
Twitter who's got more yeah and they
went up Alyssa like Anderson Cooper or
Ashton after Koecher was you they were
gonna go to give you the role that I
would have been awesome that they called
me up like you're the only one that
could save two and a Half Men and I'm
like we'll let him drown [ __ ] die we
did find out Ashton was going to be on
the show via Twitter when he tweeted
what's the square root of six point two
five I'm not good at math it's two
points Oh Charlie had to respond
naturally Charlie Sheen by the way it's
funny heat was telling people it's 85%
sure I'm gonna be back on the show and
they're gonna have me back I'm gonna go
back to work he was saying this as much
as a couple of months ago [ __ ] seven
year old woman at a Pingo flower let
your Charlie G bad zombie five he said
about Ashton Kutcher Kutcher is a
sweetheart and a brilliant comedic
performer oh wait so am I he told TMZ
calm enjoy the show America enjoy seeing
a 2.0 in the demo every Monday Warner
Brothers ha that's that one that's a
math talk again I guess that's bad 2.0
yeah they're getting about double that
in terms of the ratings when he was on
he's expecting the show to fail is what
he's saying I can't believe I mean have
you ever watched an episode to an F man
no sir I've not I came I mean you know
the premise though I do why does anybody
- then I'm not quite thats the thing I
can't quite get because they're the two
men yeah and then there's a half a man
Oh at least so it's the extra half oh
yeah that's the extra parts value Jon
Cryer's happy he's got a job he said
regarding Ashton co-starring with him on
the show ashes is an extraordinarily
talented guy and his presence will be an
asset to our show we are old friends
from our male modeling days and we're
both looking forward to being judged for
our comedic artistry as opposed to our
exceptional physical beauty during this
whole [ __ ] charleshayne thing just
imagine him sitting on top of a mailbox
in the rain crying duck is a duck each
oh yeah Denise Richards Charlie's ex by
the way we all thought she was being
very classy and low-key and quiet during
all this this debacle that Charlie was
putting him and his kids through yeah
turns out she's been saving it all for
her tell-all book she just sold it to a
publisher apparently for an untold
amount of money so we'll get to hear a
point her point of view in the book she
wasn't being classy she was being
[ __ ] save it for the money strategic
don't give it away make them pay for it
speaking of paying Marlee Matlin from
Celebrity Apprentice owes Uncle Sam
$50,000 in unpaid taxes what you are
gonna burn in hell dude you're gonna
burn how much 50 grands and unpaid taxes
okay she's in trouble for that yes what
are they doing over and can she even
hear whatever they're doing
Marley said panties I thought you said
Texas cheating it up in Dallas she was
confused now she plans on paying it was
a really awesome bad joke I think I've
spoken about liking her quite a bit in
the past how about not on this show I
not on this show oh there is my hugest
movie crush for the longest time from
children of a lesser God she's sexy in
the movie and and she's really good and
beautiful as [ __ ] but in the movie she's
like a everybody and the fat dude who
saw that movie me is there I want to
help I don't want to save her you know
as if like she were you Jenny Stewart at
the time very much I wanna help her I
want to save her Clara but I did I had
that kind of like oh she needs help you
know because she's a broken or some but
in real life if I'd ever met that
character she would be like I wouldn't
[ __ ] you with a stolen dick yeah well
she wouldn't say it she'd do this [ __ ]
and [ __ ] and I'd be like what happens
somebody to explain I'd be like whoa
well thanks a lot you'd have to hear it
twice first in sign language and then
someone at the translator true you name
the dick and interests in your decade
you would never kiss you and then maybe
a third time because I'd want
confirmation
did you really say no I need a third
person to verify the second person maybe
you're making it up exactly because the
interpreter wants to [ __ ] is what you
anxious
so now there's four people repeating it
to me in three different languages just
to make sure that she said I don't want
to [ __ ] you Lindsay Lohan in the news
again today what a week she's had she
apparently pled no contest to her
misdemeanor theft charge she going to
jail
well 120 days is what she got for her
probation violation in the pan she was
served 120 days now she's not gonna get
any charged any days for the the
misdemeanor theft because she's pleading
no contest so that is pretty much saying
I'm not admitting my guilt but I just
want this charge to go away so they're
gonna lump all of her jail time on to
her probation violation in essence she's
pleading down to a lesser charge
guys here's the thing 120 days when you
factor a good behavior and overcrowding
in the prisons
yes becomes 14 days of jail time out
really yeah from 120 to 14 and she's in
jail for two weeks yes but she also
applied to be in the home prison program
where they put a bracelet on you and you
can't leave your house yes and looks
like they're going to approve her
application for home prison so the
lesson here is we can all steal and
expect treatment just as fair and equal
what I can understand is how crowded is
her house if there's an overcrowding
issue that's why she's not doing the
full sentence if she's gonna be at home
why don't we give her 120 days of home
prison and out of the port or move some
prisoners to her house even better
apparently she's got plenty of room
totally yeah that doesn't seem fair man
yeah well let's all go steal a necklace
see what happens all right let's all go
inside and this is a rough one but I had
to talk about it Andy Dick is being sued
while we're talking about celebrity
justice Andy Dick
why you why are you moaning for him he's
a mess and he takes a hot [ __ ] mess
he was uh Matthew Brock though on
Newsradio news radio he was so good in
the show but yeah sadly in real life he
seems to get walls from time to time
what is the latest wall that Andy Dick
is it a comedy fan in Texas is suing him
because at a live show Andy was dressed
in a blond wig and a black camisole and
a red skirt and didn't have any
underwear on and he was making his way
through the crowd and the gentleman
asked Andy for an autograph
so Andy promptly crawled up on a barb's
barstool pulled down his skirt and
pressed his [ __ ] and balls against the
guy's face
is that what counts as an autograph now
how about all these people all these
years been asking for he's been writing
[ __ ] on paper they're like now put your
dick right here
Robert Tucker who filed the lawsuit did
not expect that but it's not what he was
looking for nobody expects the Spanish
Inquisition man he was suing for
defamation of conduct I don't even know
what that means but I think it means
someone puts their [ __ ] and balls
against the face infliction of emotional
distress he is suing Andy and his talent
agency and the club the comedy club
where it all took place would you like
to see some video Kevin of expressing
his [ __ ] and balls somebody had a camera
take a look
sandy climbing up on the stool he looks
a little drunk
then contact we have contact and you see
the guy running away his hand he falls
off the stool and there's his ass
hanging out yeah there you go
Oh tough man that's tough how I like in
my news radio but oh yeah what do you
think that's all about I don't know but
I'm gonna try it tonight I move I want
to press my [ __ ] against somebody
tonight so it if you reach out of your
seat I put a number under there I'm good
number 27 where's lucky lucky number 27
gets that's my [ __ ] and balls right in
your face line up for your autograph
Arnold and Murray are getting a divorce
yeah how about this after a quarter of a
century yeah it's weird he just left the
governor's office and suddenly not
getting along after 25 years
[Music]
call me cynical but they're full of [ __ ]
that's his defense yes she says now can
we go and I was having a good time no
just do one no yeah because we're
completely full of [ __ ]
Maria hasn't been with me for years now
and actually I miss her I miss her giant
chin you know when we were out together
when I didn't have sunblock on I could
seek shade under her chin or in the rain
you know I always knew I'd have a dry
place to stand
I'm the her enormous [ __ ] chin she
got a big cheer they haven't been
together for years and she's telling
friends that Arnold seems a little
unstable
dun-dun-dun he starts walking to the
police stations are you Sarah Connor
apparently she says he's got quite the
ego on him too I would imagine him to be
a modest man did you watch The Royal
Wedding at all
yes yeah me and Musa commentated on for
Ustream well we were supposed to but I
missed the whole wedding I got there
late so was it just amused by himself oh
so no I didn't know you didn't know
everybody's talking about this Pippa
Middleton I'm not familiar with Pippa
Middleton I I became familiar with the
right after the wedding that was all I
know was talking about online everyone
was going like did you see her ass you
seen possessed even Muse as soon as I
came into the comic stores we were doing
the commentary he was just like have you
seen Peppa's answers I got literally
just landed dude I missed the whole
wedding I just you saw me walk in he's
like you gotta see her ass and they
pulled up footage of her ass and it was
as [ __ ] underwhelming as the second
two Matrix movies it's like the promise
that I like oh you want this ass manners
we'll reevaluate asses for you and I saw
her she's fine nice but not like what
are you wearing chaps I mean how did
everyone look at her and everyone's
talking about like this good supposedly
amazing
that she was wearing in this dress but
this is this is her next to Harry I
guess at the wedding whatever she looks
oh yes she pretty there's no wrong kind
of looks like a lien yeah she looks way
and she looks like like a Keira
Knightley stunt double he took a couple
horse kicks to the face during during
pirates to try wearing a corset anyway I
just had no idea who she was I did not
watch the wedding but I saw the story
after the wedding she's everywhere she's
on the cover of [ __ ] People magazine
she's not even from this country's on
the cover there like Pippa fever and
there's a picture of her on the cover in
the same [ __ ] white dress but there's
also a another picture of online from a
year ago or something like that party
and she got her top off she's just
wearing a bra apparently the royal
family all up in arms about it and [ __ ]
what are we going to do about Pippa what
are we going to do about the pay uh and
they all sing cuz that's what they do in
England you know the porn company Vivid
Entertainment is offering her five
million dollars for one sex scene
that's ridiculous like she's she's from
a well-off family her family they have a
party favorite business like there we
have a party favor business the
Middleton's yeah there used to be a
flight attendants or were tea make like
matric dog poop and no sure happy
anniversary grand power [ __ ] balloons
or like Batman cake toppers and [ __ ]
that's how they made their money and so
those people come from like lots of
money so to throw five millionaires
ain't gonna mean much they would have to
be like 50 million for her to stop and
be like alright I'll suck a [ __ ] for 50
million bucks as 50 million quid is
[Music]
she's Dick Van Dyke for Mary Poppins
five in the mouth 50 million in the hand
HIPAA thinks that's awfully smart
it's a lovely holiday with him is the
one we won't define that's way too low
five million dollars that's their
opening offer she's scoffing at that I'm
guessing they're doing this for the
energy and the publicity value P she's
very popular things I would do for five
million dollars but I will offer me five
million dollars yeah yeah Ralph we'll do
it together
it'll be look like a [ __ ] german porn
it'll be filthy and they're looking for
one scene from her will do 15 yeah will
do more than he asked for laughter a
couple in the back for you know those in
the parking lot before we even get to
the set we won't even make the shoe will
be [ __ ] at home get lost in each
other is it Alicia Silverstone is a new
mom the isolations Alicia she's got a
new son his name is bear [ __ ] you
goddamnit the celebrities with the
[ __ ] names bear blue is his middle
name and they by the way it's not even
blue like [ __ ] normal blue it can't
be blue BL you it's bat titers spelling
blue for his middle name she's just
setting this kid up for a miserable
junior high experience man dude B hey
bear blue bear blue right bear blew my
[ __ ] cops up my cop
eat it Silver's don't eat my dad he's
like why'd they call me bear why
couldn't they just stopped it bear what
that bear blue balls they should call me
he's never gonna get laid there's a guy
who does the score for Battlestar
Galactica's name's Bear McCready yeah
that's a pretty cool man there's Bear
Grylls the guy who's out in the
wilderness [ __ ] like killing American
Indians with his bare hands he takes
their innards and makes a tent out of it
or something I'm not quite sure I've
never seen the show but I think it's
something like that where he kills
indigenous peoples and then makes some
sort of hobble out of their intestines
really no he's like are you an Eskimo
yeah swordsman's thinks Bear Grylls it
sounds like a guy who should be you know
oh that kind of name eating moss and
stuff or it could be more like Pooh Bear
or it could be bear meaning like the
hairy fat gay lover yes totally man I
can't [ __ ] my my kids named Harley
Quinn you know the name is something you
run from Bristol Palin was in the news
this week and her up you saw her
transformation she's denying rumors that
she had plastic surgery for cosmetic
reasons here's here's a picture of the
before and after of the Bristol
yeah it's pretty pretty significant what
did she have done she says it's not
plastic surgery it did improve the way I
look but this surgery was necessary for
medical reasons
she says her old face was making people
sick no she needed her jaw realigned she
claims I liked your tail if you go
though
her jaw and teeth had to properly
realign so they had to adjust her jaw
and apparently they had to lipo suck of
fat out of her face to get to her jaw
because now now she looks very very
different right on how old she has
nothing to do with the fact she just
signed for her own reality show right on
the way out you know because she's
America's most famous single mother that
was the press release today it says
she's the most famous single mother in
America 16 so wait how old does she know
I shot it was 19 or something like that
well I look forward to watching many
hours of her wonderful programming
around Kevin Federline's getting a
reality show awesome oh thank god
how am I ever gonna get anything done
with all this great program his
girlfriend Victoria Prince is pregnant
with his fifth child
it's motherfucker's fertile yeah it's
got some powerful the other Colm kafir
sneezes the chick gets pregnant kevin
jizz her line I've got to with the the
first chick what was her name
Shar Jackson thank you very much and
then two with Britney and now one with
this broad so I don't know what the
reality show is gonna be but hope it's
him getting a vasectomy in the first
episode I think it's all about him
single handedly repopulating the earth
so the master race like the - race Tim
and this his offspring being idiot so
like this reality show news I got more
for you okay
The Situation's dad is upset with the
situation situations dad is calling
himself the confrontation [ __ ] you're
not is he literally called he's writing
a tell-all book about his son's dark
past
Frank Sorrentino is very upset with his
son Michael Sorrentino because
apparently he wouldn't pay for his
medical bills wouldn't buy heroin or
something like that yeah medical
marijuana maybe that's the problem
he's writing a book called confrontation
with situation and he says I'm calling
Mike on his [ __ ] I've covered up for
Mike his entire life when I needed help
he left me hanging based on what he did
to me my attitude is [ __ ] that little
[ __ ]
I'm not holding anything back says Frank
would you like to see some videos [ __ ]
yeah we saw Frank talking about his son
yeah there you go
I asked you one [ __ ] favor you tell
me to go [ __ ] be like a regular
[ __ ] Joe blowing and go on welfare
not my friend
I love my son Mike but you know what
Mike when you get to the top and you
forget where you come from
somebody should remind you
I just want to remind you
that's it I love my son before
[Music]
so sit back I'm gonna tell you about the
situation I love The Godfather newzik
yeah yeah very dramatically I love you
situation but you broke my heart
I know is you situation [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah I must say that's my kid when I got
home now I know daddy learned from
another daddy tonight [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that little [ __ ] Justin Bieber
speaking of little [ __ ] marg
Helgenberger from CSI telling the truth
about Justin you see this I think she
thought because she was in France when
she gave the interview that we wouldn't
get wind of it over here but it's been
all newspapers he was a brat on the set
she says he locked one of the producers
in a closet then put his fist through a
cake that was on the craft service table
oh and that's what happened the
reenactment I'm just thinking closets
and fists or two things he probably
knows a lot about he's just doing what
comes natural Whitney Houston speaking
of things that have come naturally she's
going back into rehab we're all a lot
safer tonight Whitney's representative
says that she doesn't have a problem
she's just going back to support her
long-standing recovery process right
it's a tune up it's like Jiffy Lube of
rehab just going in just to get her oil
topped off and get some fluids changed
that's all Whitney was quoted as saying
[Music]
we'll always love you will love crack
that's what she sounds like now man have
you heard her sing better than she is
yeah it's kind of sad man I went and
listened to that clip when people were
just like oh her voice sounds like she
has it come on and she played her
singing and we had sounds pretty I guess
whatever drugs she was doing really hurt
her voice no yeah but it's worth it
[ __ ] drugs are so good yeah that's
the problem that's why people get hooked
them because they're really good cuz it
works yeah exactly
good to know Matthew Perry also in rehab
he went in rehab this week again yeah
before he's been in a couple times one
for booze one for prescription he's so
[ __ ] hard to be Matthew Perry man
this dude is always going to rehab which
means he's always doing drugs which
means he always doesn't want to be
Matthew Perry yes let's sit this dude
down and be like you're a winner man
could I be more addicting yeah I'd be
like first stop saying [ __ ] like that
number two come on have a good time you
won you did it you must have a [ __ ] ton
of friends money no yeah he says my
making plans to go away for a month to
focus my sobriety and continue my life
in recovery
please enjoy making fun of me on the
world wide web all right that's a good
joke that's a good joke then ABC
cancelled mr. sunshine hmm I wonder
which thing came first I think maybe ABC
cancelled mr. sunshine and they said I'm
going away from
I'll be back Ryan in there Matt sort of
this is a big week in TV they're telling
us all the networks you're telling us
what their [ __ ] Cannon and what they're
gonna bring on for new TV series ABC
canceled mr. sunshine V I love mr. Sun
canceled know the chick with the short
hair yeah I saw a billboard for it like
one season just to make it all season
probably I don't think so no ordinary
family the superhero family show no
particular this year I remember the
first jobs those were charted really
high gone
brothers and sisters apparently that was
a show yes okay as far as we know okay
off the map that's gone ABC's off the
map is gone what was that don't have a
[ __ ] clue what that show was on all
these shows I've never heard of better
with you better with you was canceled
what does that got me
Detroit 187 I heard of because of my
wife watched an episode or two that was
with that Christopher soprano that guy
that's gone but good news they're making
room for Charlie's Angels that's coming
back and the new Tim Allen sitcom so we
got a lot to look forward to us on I
look forward to what was that [ __ ] yes
some guys scream back there I was Tim
Allen's kid old tool time fan Richard
Karn in the back there that was not the
guy with the beard the beard is buddy
that said I think next year this time
we'll be sitting here God willing
reading a notice about the cancellation
of the new Tim Allen show yeah sure we
will they don't seem to keep much on
they don't give anything let it give it
given anything a chance anymore well you
shouldn't
most of those shows you shouldn't give a
chance fair enough you know I love my
lists yes this week Victoria's Secret
released their what is sexy list for
2011 I gotta say I'm especially glad for
this list not that I made it because
they left me off again this year
inexplicably just an oversight yeah
but they had sexiest actress was one of
the categories this year okay let me
play a little video of the Victoria's
Secret models talking about the sexiest
actress
sexiest actress this funny and fine
bombshell rocks the red carpet and done
yeah Emma Stone [ __ ]
Emma [ __ ] stone right sexiest
actress [ __ ] I forget was I ever the
guy that was like she'll never be this
egg's no but I'm dude the closest guy to
me that I can yell at Emma Stone yeah I
love surly you were on to it very I was
she is the sexiest actress you know says
so
oh just Victoria Secret models what do I
know about [ __ ] sexy everything
sexiest actress I was out of my hand
excited there was a I know this has
nothing to do with her but Victoria's
Secret in one of the cities when I was
traveling they had to close down a store
because they had a bedbug problem [ __ ]
up
could you imagine you bought a pair of
panties strap them the [ __ ] on and the
floss up your ass kind and you found now
there's like a colony of bedbugs living
in your underwear how do you get bedbugs
in new underwear it just they live in
cloth they live in anything where it's
like warm and they can nest a material
and they just wait for [ __ ] [ __ ] to
put it on like you and me I shave my
balls exactly give them nothing I don't
want anything to hold on to but fall
right off like Tom Cruise in that second
Mission Impossible movie bag hanging out
do it upside our rock also on the list
Mila Kunis got sexiest eyes no man is
Seyfried no we're gonna [ __ ] you you do
something cool
I saw Jersey girl [ __ ] you still
steaming about the beginning of the show
sexiest curve Sofia Vergara who's that
who is that how dare you sir I die you
watch modern family no you don't watch
modern family one of the funny shows on
TV my everyone in my house watch I've
never seen I've been working up at doing
stuff I've stopped doing things and
watch more TV productive and watch some
television I bet she said Harris's wife
in the show she said O'Neill's wife I
don't know with him with that Aris I
think you should know I think that's
beautiful everything was going along
fine with me with this list until I got
to to this category here what's this one
sexiest sense of humor that's what came
up on this video here second sense of
humor
[Applause]
[Music]
Chelsea Handler was given the sexiest I
will once again be the loan and get you
with that spit-take did I get you sorry
did you behave all over the guest a
little spit take nicely done families
young ladies now moist I think it's time
for a town was calm to update don't you
think so and now for this week's
countless fun update we thank you the
well Norman well thank you Dave
this week's talent update
Chelsea Handler was named sexiest sense
of humor by the Victoria's Secret what
is sexy list 2011 what the [ __ ] do they
know nothing
also Chelsea's sitcom based on her
best-selling book are you there vodka
it's me Chelsea was picked up by NBC
where to go NBC continued staying in the
basement good luck tonight by the way
tonight at another theater as we speak
where the Pantages Theater Chelsea
Handler is performing as we speak right
on her her tour is called the lies
Chelsea Handler told me tour this is the
poster for the tour by the way there's
that lies Chelsea Handler told me tour
for those of you can't be there
obviously because you're here tonight I
wanted to give you a few of the lies
that Chelsea Handler tells one she
builds it as a comedy show
line number one line number two is right
on the poster can we get a close-up of
her face of her picture on that poster
please yeah there we go I didn't know
that Julie Christie from 1965 was
playing Chelsea Handler on this tour
just made up look at that [ __ ] picture
who is that new juicer look I understand
people show business reserve the right
for a little airbrushing but don't
[ __ ] abuse the privilege look at let
look at can we get a real picture of
Chelsea Handler James can you put a real
petition there we go that's a little
honesty yeah there we go I've seen her
up close yeah very cute that's that that
crack [ __ ] 2:00 in the morning look
we've all come to know and love that's
that waking up in the morning holy [ __ ]
what did I drink last night to end up
with this succubus next to me that's
that look we've all come to know and
love oh sweet Jesus let me know off my
arm rather than wake her up and get out
of this bed you're right she's very
unpopular oh stop
straighter I'm here I'm not at the show
yeah I'm going right after let's take a
look at the geek news shall we I don't
say I don't want to say I was right
but Wonder Woman was in the news this
week yeah apparently NBC has decided not
to pick up David E Kelly's pilot of
Wonder Woman the TV series yeah no no
good really was said about this thing
all the way during the price it was very
troubled we've been tracking this story
here at Hollywood babble-on Ralph we
have it is it's not great yeah of you
and I it's no it's no surprise
whatsoever I mean it would have been it
would have been surprising if they
picked it up it right down to the
leggings dude people would pitch about
like blue legs over red boots you guys
are [ __ ] it it's a David Kelly's like
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm trying he didn't
know what he was getting into it entered
fanboy world I think he essentially did
like a 90s version of what he maybe
could have gotten away with but you
can't get away with that anymore they
want to see it serious and [ __ ] yeah so
we we won't see you Wonder Woman any
time soon that's good though that means
they might make a cinematic version then
maybe they'll go back feature so that's
that's what they said they're gonna take
the character and at least do a Justice
League film and maybe and Wonder Woman
film before that to kind of stir up
interest in the character on the big
screen so I see but I'm sure in Comic
Cons everywhere that pilot will be
floating around you'll be able to get a
copy if you really want to see it
sadly Batman was arrested in Michigan
this week and have you heard this story
or not
this 31 year old [ __ ] was dressed as
Batman on top of an Ace Hardware store
in Petoskey Michigan who's cheered for
Petoskey where did that come from
they're Petoskey Michigan they're
representing we've got a guest they're
like we can't live without the Batman we
whip their ass in football I guess he's
a rival oh you rescue a trough skis ass
and yeah right on toss skis a bunch of
[ __ ] man I've always felt that way his
name is Mark Wayne Williams Wayne how
they know a secret identity Riley yeah
really
totally here's a picture they took of
mark in the police station when they
when they brought him in yeah there he
is look at that sad fat [ __ ] right there
look at how big the bat is I know it's
made out of like electrical tape or
something it's kind of sad I think that
Batman was off by one letter they found
him on the roof of a hardware well
someone spotted him and called the
police and said there's a big fat guy
dressed as Batman help improve for the
Ace Hardware you might would have sent
someone out to take a look when they
arrested him they gave him multiple
counts because of the weapons he was
carrying apparently the utility belt was
[ __ ] stock hood look at this he had a
spray can of something called freeze
plus P which apparently is some sort of
pepper spray kind of deal he also had a
folding steel baton that he could whip
out and make it hit your ass with a
weighted sap which is one of those
blackjack kind of things you hit someone
in the back of the head let blind gloves
no that's for Superman no you throw a
punch that throws more weight beyond the
pot like he could lift those gloves
physique why would you get ready to
fight somebody if there's no super
villain yeah waiting on the roof of one
to show up he's like I'm here for that
guy we kicked your acid football Batman
on the euro you deserve Petoskey leave
us step friends a gas ejected device I'm
gonna be this guy a bludgeon and a
sandbag case there was a leak somewhere
I guess in case the river
Rose freeze Batman he reaches in the
sand throws it your face runs away that
it's for the end of the show for the
curtain to rise or something like that
police said they've run into mark before
last time they arrested him he was
dressed as the crow so marks got a lot
of time on it at least he's consistent
yes yes more geek news human target
based on the popular comic book of the
same name has been cancelled on Fox
human targets gone I like that show I
wasn't aware that he was still running
yeah I know that also opened huge but
then I hear about against I thought it
was just off Fox also canceled lied to
me the Chicago Code traffic light and
breaking in to the Lord
yeah Christian Slater and a failed TV
series that's strange
they call me one season Chris
it's been a bad week to be back man he
was arrested in Michigan and then he got
his ass kicked in Las Vegas I don't know
if you saw the video or not it was sort
of internet sensation this week I
brought it in case you missed it but
this poor [ __ ] walking down the strip
dressed as Batman said the wrong thing
to the wrong guy
and got his ass beat it's it's
heartbreaking for a Batman fan because
you'll be like he'll save us Batman will
save us yeah he doesn't know and the
worst part is this sort of his bad
kung-fu sort of defense and his 13 year
old girl slap-fight technique well you
can see for yourself here's a little
clip from from YouTube we pull there's
uh there's Batman getting into a verbal
altercation with this gentleman
and there's the bad Dean mention that
yeah and Julio just goes to town on the
cow in about a minute and it's lights
out yeah yeah yeah there we go
wait wait for the body slam and
yeah and as it is goodnight dark night
at that point as he wobbles off down the
lodge notice soak his hand in the
fountains somewhere the Joker is very
disappointed that when you look at that
it just you realize how [ __ ]
superheroes could never really work to
see that outfit and broad daylight like
no in the comics it's always like I
dress like this just scare my enemies go
out in the world in that costume people
bodyslam you in public man nobody's
afraid even if you're carrying a sand
bag with you maybe you should be a
little better fighter though before you
go out that outfit thinking maybe I
don't know spend the extra fifty dollars
on the deluxe that comes with the actual
gloves it was bare fisted not just the
cups with the points on them he's very
local about Batman a little embarrassing
movie news they are doing another remake
of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
well we haven't remade it since 2003 so
it's about [ __ ] time we got a new
Texas Chainsaw Massacre up and running
this one will be in 3d oh thank god yes
whatever I the only way to enjoy a film
ralph
three-dimension did you see Thor in 3d
when you know flat good old 2d I request
it though like you want three days at
[ __ ] you I want 2d so charge me less I
usually feel the way you do but I think
the 3d really sort of added something in
the Asgard stuff it was kind of cool
dead early ya don't need that I did go
see that you saw it last week I hadn't
known I did go see it I enjoyed it I
enjoyed that movie more than I ever
imagined I would ever enjoy a [ __ ]
Thor movie I was not a big Thor guy
growing up so I think that my level of
expectation was pretty low and that's
why I liked it so by the end of it was
like this is Thor
I have no idea was pretty badass the
only thing I didn't agree with was that
chick fell in love with him too [ __ ]
quickly Natalie Portman she's meant to
be lul brainy and [ __ ] he takes his
shirt off she's like oh my god I'm so
wet he's a god yeah thank you sir he's a
god maybe he willed her to love
you love in my eyes I'm thought that was
the boys I don't know why jon lovitz is
boy I'm the goddess I'm Natalie Portman
and you're Thor don't go back to Asgard
I love you so much but I have to Loki's
cousin trouble yeah that's it Loki all
right well if you gotta go let me just
suck your dick before you go that's God
Warner Brothers has announced their have
two teams of writers working on two
Tarzan movies at the same time to bring
the king of the jungle back to the big
screen does anybody care like seriously
unlike but not even lying without a hint
of irony is there a single [ __ ]
person in the room going like I can't
wait for a new Tarzan movie you sure
leave I just don't get how many times
can you see this [ __ ] story man been
way more interesting things that have
happened in the world of literature
fiction pop culture without reaching
back to life as the dude who was raised
by Apes ain't that [ __ ] up he swings
around a jungle like a [ __ ]
remember they did it what's his name
that dude in there Indiana Jones movie
at one point he was swinging the kid
Shia LeBouf Yeah right everyone want
nuts look Bobo right then and there we
all know no but they're done with
watching people swing on vines at movies
it's although did you see Greystoke with
Christopher Lambert and like 20 years
ago interesting take on him trying to
way back into selling doubt but it's
been done so [ __ ] move on why do we
have to watch it again man again with
like here's the story of the boy in the
jungle like I know this [ __ ] story do
the story about the boy in the J do the
story about the girl in the jungle Oh
Sheena of the jungle no girl in the
jungle you're so you're scary matter no
we do to make you happy what story do
you want me to tell just tell it
aren't you with me though like how many
times can they do [ __ ] Tarzan it
everything depends on how it's done
I thought Sherlock Holmes was a dead
character I thought who would want to
see you [ __ ] Sherlock Holmes in a
movie and then you put Robert Downey jr.
in there and you mean you put a new spin
on it I found that movie I thought it
was enjoyable alright you may kiss come
on one thing we can't agree on Will
Smith's a dick he's got two two-story
trailers in New York City right now in
the Soho neighborhood that are pissing
off the neighbors do you have a picture
of this monster I don't I couldn't find
well let me describe it I've seen it in
the newspaper this week imagine no lie
an 18-wheeler like a tractor-trailer
truck that you see for deliveries right
and imagine the trailer is done like a
customized bus right that's what it is
and it pops up on top so it becomes two
levels there's room for a 30 person
conference room in this bus yeah he uses
it for
you know his trailer but also writers
room other things go on in it it's
[ __ ] unreal though its massive I own
a bus I drive around in the bottle drive
it but get driven in it it's dwarfed by
this [ __ ] massive thing well you know
he had a second one that was his gym yes
same size right same size right next to
it and the people never like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
yeah these thing and it was unlike Bond
Street or something in Manhattan it's
this thing you know an apartment isn't
Manhattan they're looking at the window
this monstrosity parked in their
neighborhood and parked and also to keep
a trailer running you got to leave the
Jenny on I mean you could sometimes tag
into a landline but not in the middle of
Manhattan so they're probably just
running diesel fuel on that block 24
well not 24/7 but as long as the
trailers there so if you're living on
the block you're just like [ __ ] this
is miserable but the worst part about I
mean look he has no choice where they
put the trailer like you know he of
course he wants it as close to set as
possible normally that's what people do
they just wanted to move him into a
parking lot down the way but then people
got really out
when they found out where he lives for
the shoot he was renting an apartment
right there like literally I'm not gonna
say across the street but essentially
come out of his building and walked no
more in two minutes to his trailer so
people like come the [ __ ] on man just go
to your goddamn house or something like
that they finally move the trailer it's
huge though it's unreal I saw a picture
of it it's crazy dick I feel bad for him
you know it's I mean don't feel too bad
he's got a massive [ __ ] bus but at
the same time you know he's just like
taking [ __ ] for this he's like I didn't
Park it there it wasn't me you don't
need that size of a trailer know one
time if you're Will Smith I mean why not
though he's made he's making all that
money why well apparently he did say
it's the second floors for his daughter
to whip her hair back and forth so make
sure I had plenty of [ __ ] room for
that talentless little troll to be taken
care of and Jade Jaden had to take some
meetings to about his next [ __ ] film
career - that thing going on
Oh kill me now that's why they needed
the trailer for his giant [ __ ] that
trailer is as big as Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
man when you see it you'll see how you
you know that sounds like a segue move
might as well just jump in what do you
say let's do it every once in a while
every once in a while every episode we
like to talk about how big Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is now Liam Neeson's [ __ ] this
started as well Kevin's fixation he's
infatuated with Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
because I once heard that well I've
heard from many people many sources
nobody who's ever actually seen it or
touched it but that Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is [ __ ] huge huge heard that for
years first thing I got in the business
when they picked up clerks sat down they
sat down they told me all the great
mister here man one of them was Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is as big as [ __ ] a
baby's arm holding an apple if that baby
was baby Paul Bunyan
- let go out and make Mallrats
well the legend has grown and our buddy
John McGuire one of our listeners in the
he's at the the garmi base in Glasgow
Scotland I think that's right put this
together um he put Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
tumblr.com online and people have just
been going on and adding their liam
neeson [ __ ] story so every week it's
time to ask how big is Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
can only be measured using imaginary
numbers it's good Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big Stevie Wonder can see it [ __ ]
big that's a twofer man - celebrities of
that joke sometimes when the listeners
do our work for us I love it Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that when he
trims his pubes hippies climb up the
shaft and camp out to protest the
tampering with of one of God's most
glorious creations long yeah at least it
wasn't funny Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it makes you gag and choke just from
talking about it Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big if he jerks off too much we'll
all go blind Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it's sensitive about its weight
oh that's perfect for his [ __ ] now he
has a hard time finding clothes that fit
yeah
or getting out of [ __ ] Southwest
Airlines what Bali has to buy two seats
but it's swearing it can fit between the
armrest you could buckle the seat belt
around my dick it's not too fat yet
finally can't see is so big it's
architectural II impossible do you like
that on the right Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big that even to describe it we would
need to add two new vowels and five new
consonants in the alphabet Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big even Scientologists find
it hard to swallow well our religious
intolerance religion come on Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big leprechauns
found a pot of gold at the end of it
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that you go
up on him the slow pitch man broke right
at the very end where Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big that due to its gravitational
pull not even light can escape his
urethra Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
every time he goes for a swim Japanese
fishermen try to kill it and finally
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when it
writes a check a sperm bank fails I love
that man y'all have a good time tonight
thanks so much for coming out everybody
go out and buy some goddamn man grades
everybody have a great week we'll see
you next week for Hollywood babble-on
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman babble
the [ __ ] off
[Applause]
[Music]